In Kyiv central train station
and about to go to Kharkiv
and Kharkiv, I've done about
five minute of research on this place.
So I have absolutely no idea
what I'm getting into.
[train station announcement]
♪ deep house music ♪
Kharkiv, Ukraine...
Way out in the far East of the country.
30 kilometers from the Russian border.
First impressions, it was dark
but I could see a lot of street life.
Like a lot of people on the street
lot of young people.
♪ busker playing guitar ♪
[music fades]
[exhales]
Day one.
These building here, this architecture
it does it for me, this constructivism.
Such creative lines.
Such beautiful proportions
They have a building here,
I think it's the opera house.
Like a small planet landed on earth.
It's just this massive hunk of weight.
It's so ugly, it's a little bit beautiful.
There's all these kids outside of it.
Skateboarding, people hanging out.
There's fountains, it's nice.
♪ deep house ♪
[skateboard clacking]
Shashka is crushing it
on the skateboard here.
Nice moves, Shashka.
-How old are you?
-15.
PETER: 15, nice, bro.
[music fades]
This is what I so much love about Ukraine.
Is that it's properly mixed up.
So you have that Soviet relic behind me
and then...
[exhales]
This.
♪ melodic electronic ♪
And then these side streets.
Tree-lined side streets.
Some quiet, some with little gardens.
Like apartments, gardens, street.
[music continues]
[music fades]
[radio advertisement]
Okay, first impression of this square was
"Okay, here's a
big cobblestone parking lot
but then it opens up into this stuff.
This is super impressive,
this architecture.
And then you get into it
and it's like
design
and style is in the DNA of this place
because you go into that metro
and
it's the most beautiful metro I've seen.
Like no joke, the most
outrageous metro stops.
There was one that just
looked like a crazy science experiment.
♪ electronic ♪
[metro slowing]
♪ deep electronic ♪
[doors close and safety horn sounds]
[train accelerates]
[music fades]
A lot of eclectic businesses here.
Like coffee shops, restaurants...
World class.
You won't get these
in a lot of American cities.
Like it's just not even
that progressive in many US cities.
Even in a lot of Europe
and then you find yourself...
You know...
Near the front lines of a war.
A country that's
gone through a lot of turbulence.
A lot, right?
But there's this creative energy.
Like there's this amazing
creative energy coming out of there
and so it's designing,
building and operating
all these cool businesses here.
Very good.
[Ukrainian]
PETER: And then there's, boom.
This new cat parlor
and it's beautiful.
It's like, done well.
And then you come out of that
and there's a massive old Soviet mural
and then there's one of the most
beautiful metro stations on the planet.
And there's a tractor going by
and then there's a BMW going by.
And then there's an amazing restaurant
and then there's a place called Mafia.
I don't know how the food...
It's a chain, I doubt it's amazing food
but what I'm saying is it's like all...
[woosh woosh woosh]
It's either that extreme
or the other extreme.
They seem to be enjoying themselves.
Okay, there's a lot of
pessimistic negative bullsh*t.
Got it, but there's also a lot of this
young, vibrant, positive energy here
and it seems connected.
It seems like
you're walking down the streets
and you're part of something
bigger than yourself.
Way more diverse
than anywhere I've seen in Ukraine so far.
So you're seeing black people.
You’re seeing Arabs.
You're seeing Asians.
It felt a little bit more
like home in that respect
because it was all mixed up
and that's because of the universities.
People come from all over
to go to these universities.
And then you got these parks, right?
And these parks...
Gorky Park was the one
I spent the most time in.
Old ladies dancing.
There's kids on carnival rides.
There's people riding bikes.
There's quiet spaces.
There's people shooting guns at balloons.
It's all mixed...
Oh, and all these ropes.
These rope apparatuses for kids.
It's like a kid's paradise in there.
♪ indy rock ♪
[people screaming on roller coaster]
And it's buff, the grass, perfect.
The whole space is like perfectly clean.
There's all these cleaners out there
and the really take...
They really take pride
in their parks here.
There's no trash on the ground.
It's nice.
And so I walked around for a bit
and then took this gondola ride
and there's a gondola in the park
and
cool unique experience for me.
But if I'm gonna talk about a park
where people are connecting
to take your kids
to do a whole host of different things
then Gorky Park is the coolest
number one place I've seen for that.
Look, the Ukrainians know how
to do the whole park thing really well.
Like professional.
Where Americans are
crazy on the whole safety thing
like safety warnings for everything.
Ukraine goes
the opposite direction I'd say.
For example.
[latch clanks]
[door creaks and latch closes]
Doesn't really close either but...
You could push it
and go flying out of this thing
and
I like the fact... [clears throat]
Okay, you don't wanna
lose your kid flying out of a gondola
but I think people get it.
They're not stupid about it
but I like the fact
that you're responsible for yourself.
There are no "No" signs.
Little kid like hooking himself in.
The kid's doing it
and then he's gonna
fly across the zip line.
There's no way that would exist at home
because there'd be more safety precaution.
There'd be like three people checking it.
I don't know what's better or worse.
Seriously I don't
but I sort of find it entertaining
to observe this place and how free it is.
Then I met this guy.
Okay, poor Daniel,
I captured him on the streets.
Recently out of university.
-Looks like what?
-Like Hogwarts.
-From Harry Potter.
-Dude, I never read Harry Potter.
-C'mon but you (saw) the movie?
-No, I haven't.
-You have to, it's so beautiful.
-All right.
Next time. [laughs]
Like I think he's only...
Sorry Daniel, I think
you're only 22, right?
Or 23, but somewhere around there.
That building
is like architecture porn though.
[chuckles]
You know what I mean?
It's absolutely beautiful.
DANIEL: Yes.
PETER: But inside you're saying
it's a cockroach?
There's nothing going on in there?
When I moved to United States
and first see your cockroach
I was so pissed off.
Wait, you saw your
first cockroach in the US?
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
Got a job for a trucking company,
actually an American company.
So your roommate Simon has got to
live with you and your girlfriend?
DANIEL: Yes.
-Poor guy.
-No, I mean he like it.
He likes it?
[laughing]
That seems interesting,
let's talk a minute.
No, no, you're taking it out of context.
-No, I mean...
-I always do.
You said we have to have a pass inside
to get into the university?
Yes, but we don't have it, so...
But I'm in with
the Babushka Mafiosa in Kyiv
and they're all connected
like Facebook and aspen trees.
Do you think so?
PETER: Babushka Mafiosa
knows more about you
-than you know about yourself.
-Yeah.
She knows if you're gonna be successful.
If it's gonna work out
with your girlfriend.
Will you get married?
All these things
you don't even know right now.
Check it out, you know why this is here?
DAVID: No.
PETER: In the metro
it's this door that comes over.
DAVID: Okay.
And this, what you're standing on
Stalin built them this way
as a bomb shelter.
-So seriously if the nukes came...
-Seriously?
The population of the city
would come down in here.
Maybe in the United States of Ukraine.
No, no, no...
Designer doesn't care.
No, no, this is
why it was built, seriously.
-That's what I was told at least.
-Who told you?
Uh, I don't remember,
it was a while ago.
How do I say it? Like...
There's a lot of
mature young people I would say.
I have been in Spain over there
and Poland but it doesn't count
because Poland is almost Ukraine.
-Okay.
-And I will move to Georgia in November.
So during one year
it's gonna be my third country.
-So I mean...
-Dude, that's amazing.
It's enough.
Still not enough for my girlfriend.
♪ Hare Krishna buskers  ♪
Oh, yeah.
Very good book.
Recommendation for my friends in USA,
very good book.
Look at that, man.
That's cool.
[Peter exhales]
That is huge.
That's what she said.
[David giggles]
-Do you know that joke?
-Yes, I know.
It's from Wayne's World.
A movie in the 80s before you were born.
Okay, you're so old so you remember.
So old I could be your dad.
-We already went over this.
-Yeah.
You didn't believe me but it's true.
PETER: And there's an amazing amount
of wisdom I would say.
Maybe I was just totally lucky
but I don't think that's the case.
I actually do think
that's in sort of like the...
The DNA of this place.
Ukraine in general...
I'm gonna say my impressions here
in Kharkiv are like, "Wow."
A lot of impressive young people.
DAVID: I think it's the purpose
of your life to do what you like
because when you can spend
all your life just working on a job
just making some money
when you're gonna be like, I don't know,
60 sitting in a chair thinking
"What for I did spend the whole life?"
"Just for some money?"
"And what is that? Stressing?"
And then there's Victoria.
She's 17, she went to the US
when she was 15 as an exchange student
and she ends up
in the Deep South of the US.
And she talks like...
[Victoria talking in background]
All her mannerisms,
like everything she does
She talks like she's from the Deep South.
I'm sorry, I'm excited.
My heart...
All the problems...
African American family hosted me
and look what you have.
[all laughing]
They've created a monster.
You know, just talking, blah, blah.
Myself and then this girl
was thinking she was...
And then this girl came in...
She was trying to steal my boyfriend.
I was like, "What? I'm not even
interested in Mexicans." you know?
I don't need that.
My black mother...
and she said, "Hey, you gotta come
and pick up this girl."
And everything, we were dancing,
jamming, twerking, you know, a bit...
And all this stuff,
that was the best experience ever.
Thank you.
Victoria, yeah I'm future....
[all laughing]
But it's cool to have family
in another part of the world.
[traffic]
I met this guy here, his name is Bagdan.
Bagdan has an English language bar.
Yeah, we can only speak English
and some Ukrainian.
If you're brain is exploding.
Like you are tired of English.
You can turn into Ukrainian, no charge.
PETER: And so he brings in
all these people from around the world.
It's like super multi-cultural.
He created a cool world here.
♪ jazz trumpet ♪
What makes a place is people,
always does, right?
And maybe I'm lucky,
maybe I got lucky here.
I just seem to run into
so many cool people.
And for those from here,
from this beautiful city, thank you.
A lot of people reached out
and showed me around.
-Don't worry about it.
-Only you can understand me.
[hands slap]
VICTORIA: What's up, Peter?
PETER: What's up?
The sun is up but it's gonna go down soon
and wanna get a cool time lapse.
So this bridge situation here in Kharkiv
is quite spectacular.
♪ busker playing acoustic guitar ♪
[music fades]